liu le monde sait ce quiz aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur la mazda6 l'ip la démo
était sorti il ya des mois et des mois
et j'avais pas fais au dessus pour ceux
qui ne connaîtraient pas la
particularité de ce jeu d'horreur c'est
qu'on joue un bébé voilà on y est tout
simplement dans la peau d'un bébé d'où
mon imitation de bébé plutôt atteint
d'une grave maladie dont l'intro les
couleurs c'est quoi c'est de l'eau d'une
piscine à une piscine en verre ça va
plus tu as déjà terminé de boire à la
petite piscine appelés vers d'autres
m'en fais attention c'est fragile à metz
et des indications encore une minute
maman voiture que le gâteau est
parfaitement cuit bon et je me la joue
en attendant faire un truc je peux jouer
avec cette balle là c'est mon
anniversaire
on regarde toi tu adores à d'autres je
sais que j'ai mal aux par contre tu
étais un peu bizarre les yeux un peu
écarté fin c'est pas je t'aime maman
merci tu as deux ans aujourd'hui oui
d'où les de bouger mais je peux une
petite fille qui aimerait goûter le
gâteau c'est moi maman nos tâches
marchands de carton park 1 1
je reviens d'accord quelqu'un a frappé à
la porte elle va voir qui c'est
ouais et pourquoi on est grand on se met
à trembler qu'est-ce qui se passe elle
revient coucou à voici le cadeau
s'étaient livrés en fait ou pas du tout
mais en tout cas elle un cadeau je me
demande bien ce que c'est on va l'offrir
en oui le cas à dos le cadeau mordait
dans la peau d'un bébé comme ça oh oui à
la petite intro qui fait plaisir à le
petit noir qui fait moins plaisir tu me
dégoûtes n'avance que la pas voir
l'intérêt de tourner je vois pas grand
chose quoi et voilà oui voyons se voir
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur c'est
peut-être un nouveau jouet voilà ma puce
soit sage maintenant on revient tout de
suite emmené on me laisse pas seul à
j'ai cru qu'ils allaient me posé sur une
étagère et partir quoi première mission
évadez-vous la tombelle à bucquoy dans
le cadeau à hamster ou comment ça se
passe y'a pas une sorte de clé un truc
cacher quoi tu es un cadre de la foire
ce bébé ah ben voilà il faut que je dire
ça maintenant oui elle pense avoir
enfermé pas du tout quoi
ce but est un dangereux psychopathe quoi
il a mis au point une sorte de tunnel
souterrain passage secret c'est génial
espace pour y escalader yes l'évasion du
bébé hopla nickel le cadeau maintenant
enfoncé photo n'est pas souri pour
ouvrir un tiroir ou d'accords ou cash
jusqu'à c'est le front à mais attendez
on peut pas s'en servir comme l'escalier
mais nous le cadeau n'y a rien dedans
c'est du pur fake c'est quoi ce bouton
oh oui le trader voit même nos petits
pieds de bébé courts poèmes dansés
enfin ok peut pas rester debout trop
longtemps au d'accord donc donc là ce
jeu n'est plus tout ce à quoi je pensais
que je m'appelle teddy enchanté et toi
comment tu t'appelles moi c'est carlos
barbas vous n'est ce pas oui je suis un
bébé quoi qu'ils ont un jeu je sais je
vais cash éléphants roses mais ne
regarde pas ah là là mais vois-tu pu
cacher un éléphant rose mais arrête de
me coller quoi tu as un gros problème là
en plus il se frotte les mains à quoi
paul biya gluck haut mais où est donc au
mais que vois-je un cul d'éléphants
roses et thé la fin rien et maintenant
coups de pied coups de coups de pied
d'un teddy sa lutte et d'y aller il faut
trouver un endroit sombre bas le placard
pourquoi bah voilà pourquoi pas dans le
pack a on va bien se heurter dit faut
qu'on fasse encore plus sombre ferme
bien les portes je veux pas me faire de
trucs bizarres dans placard comme ceux
s'était dit là c'est un endroit
somptueux font très peur tu peux me
serrer fort dans tes bras 7e rassurera
peut-être un peu appuyé sur f pour
câliner jours s'était dit aux effets de
la lumière en fait pas un pas car c'est
une porte secrète à la selas c'est là
que l'horreur intervient d'un camping
car ou en train de se dire est ce que
c'est vraiment un jeu d'horreur c'est
quoi cet endroit je crois que quelqu'un
arrive je suis là hôpital à ses grandes
jambes m'ont fait peur quoi que fais-tu
lanta car rien je nettoie les vestes
jouer avec ton nouveau copain doit pas
cacher tu fais peur à maman maintenant
c'est l'heure de faire dodo au nom
couchepin temps tu pourras te lever tôt
demain et jouer avec ton copain oh oui
maintenant
l'argument qui retourne le cerveau d'un
bébé qu'au nom black screen qui chante
on se réveille je suppose qu'on en
pleine nuit
teddy watts brett attendait mais on
notera petites nappes est dédé mais qui
fait ça quoi teddy mais non mais non ma
au mac il n'a pu monter dit aux machines
à quad n attendais mais c'est ouf watts
se met debout on est des grands garçons
protègent moins apte à bord et abat
d'accord faut que je pousse pour vers la
porte et yaya quoi y'a un avion qui
décolle tous les besoins
cette sorte d'élan bruit portes ouvertes
mais à quelqu'un qui j'ai villa à j'aime
pas trop ça teddy à témoin c'est ça tdt
dit il ya un problème on doit trouver ta
maman viens avec moi teddy ces partis
teddy tata ne faut pas faire de bruit
qui sait on nous écoute peut-être je
vois rien ok on est dans oi au hockey ou
le futur de formes géométriques alpha
oméga
il ya des bruits quelqu'un mange des
chips guide moi et que je si c'est cassé
mais ce qui s'est passé ici c'est à dire
des des fruits et légumes qu'est ce que
c'est que ça fait c'est quoi ça c'est
ton ami pas mon radiateur au grand
radiateur grand radiateur divin hockey
montrent ce parti on va courir monter
dit à les aider on doit s'en aller
couraud hors de cette maison hantée
vivons notre histoire d'amour jusqu'au
bout ok oui si l'agent de maman non elle
bouge elle est vivante et si je fais les
appels de phares 20 des appels de teddy
non ya pas la clé dans un tiroir
non s'il faut être débile pourquoi écrit
pas créer un coup la sava l'a réveillé
et va faire en question fait dans le
placard ou qu'il est mignon
bon il faut monter un à temps hop aux
mecs le pouvoir fait deux mètres et demi
quoi puisqu'il faut pour ouvrir la porte
à la diva sauvegarde en cours ça marche
mama mama battant et elaia deux groupes
quoi c'est quoi ce feu au [ __ ] sous
les saouler sous les mangas tels qu elle
rêve elle se téléporte quoi carrément
protège-moi tête de hamster
c'est bon allez tu as fait ton table des
gages sur ça va taper la fin du mois
allez on y va s'appliquer aux chanter
dans ma maison
pourquoi tu sens ya pas de sens tout à
l'heure elle s'est hâté de chanter elle
m'a senti ça sonne la main walt tease
d'at&t mais c'est quoi ce truc noir la
[ __ ] t'es mange des fruits et légumes
il vous des portes des places des
chaises fin
oui ma mort je t'ai trouvé un style à
yagg
c'est un bug ou danser dans le jeu
vraiment ok ça marche
ceci que ça oh je sais ce que c'est je
ne sais pas te dis jamais posé la même
question voiture qui est cette femme
blanche à genoux est ce que tu peux voir
tour est joué cl on dirait que c'est un
souvenir
tu puisses tu me donnes et qu'est ce que
c'est de l'argent de l'argent pour
m'acheter des huit brousse c'est ça
assez mignon maman ok bon bah merci pour
le médaillon tas pour faire l'inventaire
ok on a un inventaire carrément faut
qu'on aille là dedans je suppose bien
évidemment qu'il faut peu s'atténuer
[Musique]
quel est cet endroit et battent les dix
j'allais poser une question megaman pour
enfants ce qu'est ce que ça fait là
verrouillez situe match pourrait
peut-être entrer ouvrir de l'intérieur
je peux te faire entrer par le trou
voilà hélas elle ouvre paléo pour
l'entente faire la fête avec toutes les
autres dit pourquoi tu m'as fait ça
merci tu ai dit qu'est ce que c'est que
tout ça n'est que ça va vers cette porte
il doit bien avoir bien de l'ouvrir
j'approuve à seller de l'énigme à mettre
là-dedans
hop voilà est maintenant aux caisses en
met un coup de porte déjà fait une
fracture du front pas de merci faut
qu'on tourne ça je suppose up regarde
qui s'est passé pourquoi ça ne s'ouvre
pas et tu trouvais ça c'est petit mais
je pense que ma patte le passé et moi
pas mal de passer à un bouton
vasilija puis il semble que souviens que
je partage avec ta mère a permis
d'ouvrir la porte peut-être qu'en
trouvant d'autres souvenirs nous
retrouvons ta maman alors allons-y
partout l aventure qui dit on y va tout
de suite
allez c'est parti on sent que les fleurs
et c'est parti on y va ah yes on en a
après le toboggan découvrez le cercle
qui tourne
il est donc bon ok on va sûrement de
cette tour là-bas de l'autre côté du
pont on dirait un autre souvenir comment
faire pour aller au sommet de la tour et
là ont fait contrepoids en posant sa là
dessus est exactement comme ça et à tous
les coups ça va pas suffire
un [ __ ] j'en étais sûr il faut qu'on
parte à la recherche là dedans c'est
quoi ces solitaires a bien sûr que non
c'est une cabane à de dangereux
quoi une au matin qu'est-ce qui se passe
bon bah j'attends ah oui il va bien sûr
c'est beaucoup moins joyeux d'artichaut
faire très attention technique du rush
en bp sera pas très vite mais technique
gauche un ballon on pourra proposer un
bon gros deal aux monstres je proposerai
ce ballon en échange de la vie c'est lé
symbole alors je pense que dans chaque
truc doit y avoir un hibou hop les
ouates ça marche
j'ai pas du tout où on va on y va c'est
un drame et donne la chair de poule
j'espère que ta maman va bien j'ai été
la même chose teddy hibou est à nous le
décès aussi désolé créatures je ne peux
pas de sauver parce que je suis égoïste
hockey et de 1 faisait applaudir à aller
bon oui web c'est lui bout je vois mais
je peux pas le prendre c'est horrible
stade à d'avoir un piège active et voilà
hop là mon gars qui suis dit ça allez
hop le hibou et haddou est pourquoi on
prend pas directement ce hibou là tu
fais 4 tonnes le truc resterait bien
comme ça hop qui joue sur mon terrain je
contrôle la côte ouest de la zone
c'est mon territoire ici assez encore un
tournicoti tournicoton comme on active
ah [ __ ] arrière moins active et
peut-être en allant sur les rochers
comme indiqué ci là ça qu'on veut
imitation ni qu'elle allonge toi mon
gars qui se passe je suis jean louis
fougère laura manche et indétectables je
veux vivre qu aux l'est elle est debout
on y va yes
et ça nous mais nous ça nous sommes
désormais aux côtés de tarzan
allez on continue on continue on y
célèbre on doit attendre le pont tu as
passé truc pas net en bas je suis
tellement content d'avoir réussi à
m'enfuir de là-bas quoi au café remet ça
ok c'est l'heure du pont je vous ai mes
amis hibou merci pour votre aide
précieuse et je me katz a alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a un souvenir
allez encore une fois mais après c'est
tout d'accord maintenant maman
enfin on doit plus être très loin à
l'est de chargement up et hop fracturé
la jambe
on a réussi on de très loin de sortie du
site se met à l'abri abbas est bon on a
le deuxième jouer ta mère tu es tu me
parles mieux encore elle jouait très
inquiète pour toi on va la tirer la
sphère toi et moi bon tu sais quoi
empressées dès maintenant
oui hop troisième facteur du front
autour de ça à fond plat et en fait
c'est à saint ex ben quoi c'est avec sa
main qui bouge et le truc comme ça mais
ton doigt dans le trou où teddy voilà la
mer cité dit la voix de ta mère semble
le plus net maintenant vite il n'y a pas
de temps à perdre
j'approuve à la tension tu mets les
pieds oui oui proulx c'est promis c'est
promis maman j'arrive oui ma religion
c'est déjà attendait c'est déjà la fin
sept frères vidéo sur le manque de ce
type si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me
les vidéos ça fera plaisir on se
retrouve très vite pour la suite chiots
et voir ce qui va se passer simplement
parce que là c'est pas que j'ai pas trop
confiants santé dit mais un peu quand
même
je sais que c'est mon seul ami dans ce
jeu mais il me fait peur c'est tout le
monde puisse alors éclaté ni nouvelles
ou est ce que je fais à voter non
[Musique]
c'est